[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم وتقبل الله صومكم خرجت مظاهرات
في مدن سوريه مختلفه تحت شعار حتى نغير ما
بانفسنا ياتي هذا فيما افاد ناشطون
السوريون بان قوات النظام تشن حمله على حي
القابون الدمشقي بالتزامن مع قصف مناطق
اخرى في ريف العاصمه ولم يهدا قصفها
المستمر منذ اسبوعين على مدينه حمس نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من
زاويتين ما هو طبيعه التغيير الذي ينشده
المتظاهرون السوريون من قوى المعارضه حتى
يتحقق ما دعوه انتصار
الثوره وخيارات قوى المعارضه السوريه
للتعامل مع التاخر البريطاني والامريكي في
دعمها بالسلاح
حتى نغير ما بانفسنا شعار بدا دعوه من
متظاهرين سوريين في مدن مختلفه الى قوى
وكتائب المعارضه الى تغيير نهجها لتحقيق
ما وصفوه انتصار الثوره وقد دعوا المجتمع
الدولي لدعم الجيش السوري الحر فيما اظهر
مجلس العموم البريطاني والكونجرس الامريكي
قلقا من السعي لتسليح المعارضه السوريه
وقع هذا في وقت تك ثف فيه القوات النظاميه
قصفها المستمر لمدينه حمس منذ اسبوعين
فيما تشن حمله عسكريه على حي القابون
الدمشقي ومناطق مختلفه من ريف
العاصمه يسود القلق والترقب سائر الصعود
المتصله بالازمه السوريه خرج المتظاهرون
في عده مدن في جمعه سموها حتى نغير ما
بانفسنا تعبيرا عن قلقهم من تاخر الاطاحه
بنظام الرئيس بشار الا اسد رغم مرور 28
شهرا على اندلاع الثوره ودعى المتظاهرون
قوى المعارضه لنبذ خلافاتهم ويواصل النظام
عمليته العسكريه بمختلف الاتجاهات استمر
القصف الصاروخ والمدفع الكثيف على حمص
وريفها لليوم الرابع عشر بكل الدمار
الواسع الذي يحدثه بالمساكن والبنى
التحتيه ودور العباده وغيرها وتزايدت
نداءات الاغاثه واجلاء الجرحى في دمشق
وريفها حمله النظام مستمره تسقط المزيد من
القتلى والجرحى ويوصف القصف الان بانه
الاعنف بحي القابون وتحاول قوات النظام
اقتحام الحي تحت غطاء القصف الكثيف رغم
تصدي عناصر الجيش الحر التي تعمل لافشال
الاقتحام يقول الجيش الحر ان عناصره سيطرت
خلال يومين على معظم الفرقه السابعه عش في
الرقه واحياء في دير الزور وحلب وعلى طريق
اريح اللاذقيه ودرعا ولكن قادته لا يخفون
قلقهم من تاخر تسليح الجيش الموعود رغم
تطمينات المقدمه في هذا الصدد والواقع ان
مساله التسليح ما زالت تراوح مكانها
اللجان الاستخباراتيه المختصه بالكونجرس
الامريكي متحفظه وتقول ان الاسلحه قد لا
تحسم الصراع وربما تصل لعناصر تنظيم
القاعده وفي بريطانيا الزم مجلس العموم
رئيس الوزراء بالحصول على موافقه المجلس
على اي قرار يتعلق بتسليح المعارضه
السوريه مع منحه حق الاعتراض على اي من
خطواته ويستمر الل المتعلق بالفوضى
والخلافات بين قوى المعارضه بلغ الامر
الذروه بمقتل عضو بارز بقياده الجيش الحر
بايدي تنظيم دوله العراق والشام الاسلاميه
وهو ما اعتبره الجيش اعلانا للحرب مما قد
يفتح جبهه قتال جديده تزيد التعقيدات
الراهنه بما تجلبه من تداعيات
قاسيه معنا في هذه الحلقه من انطاكيا
العقيد عبد الحميد زكريا المتحدث باسم
رئاسه اركان القياده المشتركه للجيش
السوري الحر من بيروت كمال دبيان الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ومعنا هنا في الاستوديو
اللواء الدكتور فايز الدويري الخبير في
الشؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه اهلا
بضيوفنا جميعا نبدا من انطاكيا والعقيد
عبد الحميد
زكريا حتى نغير ما بانفسنا كيف فهمتم هذا
الشعار بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم حقيقه نحن
نفهم هذا الشعار بانه مطلب اساسي وملح
وكان يجب العمل عليه منذ فتره طويله دعنا
سيدي الكريم نسمي الامور
بمسمياتها نحن لا يمكن لنا ان ننتصر على
النظام الاسدي الغاشم الا بتوحيد صفوفنا
النظام وهو دوله كامله يتلقى كافه انواع
الدعم والمساعده من دول عديده يعمل على
تجميع قواه للعمل بشكل افضل فما بالكم نحن
كجيش حر لسنا بمؤسسه حقيقيه ولا نمتلك كل
الامكانيات اللازمه للق قتال يجب علينا ان
نرص صفوفنا هذا الامر يتجلى كما يلي يجب
ان تكون هناك قياده عسكريه حقيقيه وفاعله
تملك كل سبل السيطره والتحكم على الارض لا
يكفي من بعض الاخوه المقاتلين ان يقول نحن
نتبع لهيئه الاركان وان تكون هذه التبعيه
شكليه نحن نقدر عاليا كل من خرج في هذه
الثوره نصره للشعب المظلوم ولكن علينا ان
نعترف بان الثوار المدنيين ونحن نجلهم جدا
جدا ولكن يجب ان نقول لا يمكن لهم القيام
باكثر مما قاموا به علينا جميعا ان نعمل
وفق خطط عسكريه احترافيه لقد قاموا فيما
مضى بتحقيق العديد من الاهداف السهله
البسيطه ضد ضد النظام وقواته ال كانت
متفرقه هنا وهناك ولكن طالما ان النظام
اليوم قد جمع قواته فعلينا ان نعمل نحن
اضعف الايمان بعمل مماثل بان تكون قياده
حقيقيه بتجميع قوانا بالاستفاده من كميات
الاسلحه البسيطه المتوافره بين ايدينا نحن
نعد اهلنا في سوريا اذا كانت هناك نوايا
صادقه من القاده الميدانيين للعمل تحت
قياده عسكريه احترافيه بالمعنى الحقيقي
للكلمه ان نحقق النصر في القريب
العاجل طالما تحدثتم سي سيد العقيد طالما
تحدثتم عن الثوار المدن والثوار العسكريين
هنا اسال السيد كمال
دبيان ان ان تخرج هذه الشعارات في مظاهرات
للثوار المدنيين اذا اخذنا هذا التعبير
برايك ما الذي تعنيه بالنسبه للثوار
العسكريين يعني هذا عم يعني ما يحصل هو
عمليه نقض ذاتي انا كما رايت الشعار اليوم
ان نغير بانفسنا لان الواقع على الارض
يثبت ان الثوره تراجعت عن
اهدافها هناك عمليات قتل متبادله هناك
عمليه فوضه في المناطق التي سميت محرره
هناك مناطق اي تطبق فيها الشريعه هناك
مناطق يسود فيها الخطف والقتل هناك عصابات
تقوم ب
باعمال السرقه وال والاغتصاب يعني هذه
الثوره اظهرت نفسها انها ليست ما ي يريده
الشعب السوري من تغيير للنظام يعني هذا
مستقبل
سوريا
يقدمه من من استولى على المناطق و وكما
اعترف العقيد عبد الحميد ان لا قياده
عسكريه بعد عامين ونصف العام لا معارضه
موحده لحكومه مؤقته قيل انها ستتشكل
استقال رئيسها غسان هيتو وقبله رئيس
الائتلاف الوطني السوري هناك فوضه عارمه
لذلك لن يقدم لهذه الثوره اي ايه مساعده
لان البديل عن النظام هو الفوضه الخلاقه
والاقتتال
وال والنهب و والسرقات وهذا ما ما لا
يريدها الشعب السوري نعم هذا النقد الذاتي
الذي اشار اليه سيد ذبيان دكتور دويري هل
تراه ضروريا الان بعد 28 شهرا تقريبا من
اندلاع الثوره في سوريا هو في الواقع يعني
يجب انلا نحمل الامور اكثر مما تحتمل اولا
عندما بدات الثوره اول سته اشهر باعتراف
الرئيس السوري كانت الثوره غير مسلحه ومن
ثم بدا عسكره الثوره وبالتالي عندما بدا
عسكره الثوره لم يتم ب بهذه لم تنطلق هذه
البدايه من قاعده صلبه كان هناك انشقاقات
كان هناك مدنيين يقودوا جماعات وبالتالي
كان عندنا اكثر من 100 تنظيم مسلح داخل ما
يسمى بال المعارضه العسكريه الان خلال
مسيره الثوره كان هناك تاخير في افراز
قياده فاعله ثم افرزت القياده واستلم
اللواء سليم ادريس رئاسه ار كانان الجيش
الحر بعد بعد العقيد الان اللواء سليم
ادريس حقيقه لا يمارس القياده بمفهومها
الحقيقي القياده والسيطره ولا توجد ولا
يوجد بناء تنظيمي متكامل ولا توجد قنوات
لايصال الاوامر والتعليمات هذا له اسباب
الكثيره بسبب ان الاطياف المعارضه المسلحه
ليست جميعها مدنيه عسكريه ليست جميعها اي
تشرب من نفس المشرب هناك تمويلات مختلفه
من من جهات مختلفه لها ارهاصات واسقاطها
ولكن عندما نتحدث عن ما جرى من اقتتال
علينا ان نتحدث عليه خارج اطار الجيش الحر
لان ما حصل هو ليس بين وحدات الجيش الحر
وان حصل هناك بعض الاشكاليات هناك يوجد
تنظيم القاعده في العراق وبلاد الشام يوجد
تنظيم جبهه النصره وهي تنظيمات اصلا لم
تنضوي اصلا تحت قياده الجيش الحر وهنا
مكمل الخطوره ان هذه الجماعات ت منسق
ميدانيا لتحقيق بعض الاهداف الانيه ولكن
الهدف الاستراتيجي البعيد لكلا الطرفين
مختلف الجيش الحر يسعى الى دوله مدنيه
ديمقراطيه الجماعات الراديكاليه تسعى الى
دوله خلافه اسلاميه وبالتالي بدا الاقتتال
مبكرا كان يجب تاخير هذا الاحتكاك البيني
والاقتتال
الداخلي لما بعد انهاء المشروع الاساسي
وهو اسقاط النظام الان التوحيد ضروري
وتحدثنا ك كثيرا عن ضروره توح وحيد
القياده وتوحيد الجهد وتوحيد التخطيط
العملياتي والا ستبقى المعارضه السوريه
تواجه تحديا كبيرا في سبيل تحقيق اهدافها
نعم اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار ما تفضلت
بذكره الان الدكتور دويري وما قاله ضيفنا
في في بيروت بان ما يجري هو بدايه عمليه
القد ذاتي هنا نسال العقيد زكريا الا
تشعرون في القياده العسكريه بان المواطن
السوري وكانه اصبح يتحمل عبين عبء النظام
يقنعه باستمرار باستمرار وعب معارضه لم
تلبي الطموحات التي كانت تعول عليها في
البدايه سيدي الكريم ما تفضل به ضيفكم من
بيروت هو مناف للحقيقه تماما نحن عندما
ننقد انفسنا لا يعني وجود كل ما ذكره من
سلبيات هناك بعض الامور السلبيه البسيطه
جدا والتي يمكن ان تتواجد في اي مجتمع دون
حتى وجود ثوره فما بالك بوجود هكذا ثوره
عظيمه نحن عندما ننقد انفسنا ننقد من اجل
الوصول الى مكان افضل هيئه الاركان هي
مؤسسه عسكريه تعمل بكل امكانياتها وجهودها
ولكن مع كل اسف لم تتلقى الدعم الحقيقي
للوصول الى اهدافها المطلوبه اعود الى
سؤال حضرتك نعم المواطن السوري اليوم يدفع
اعباء كثيره سواء من النظام او سواء من
الطرف الاخر لكن من طرفنا نحن لسنا
مسؤولين عن ذلك كوننا لا نملك الامكانيات
اللازمه للعمل الصحيح سيدي الكريم ال
المواطن السوري اليوم يتعرض لامرين الامر
الاول هو الاخلال بامنه والامر الثاني
الاخلال وتهديده بلقمه عيشه النظام يقوم
بهذين الامرين تماما فمن نجى من القتل من
طائرات الاسد مات جوعا بسبب هذا الحصار
الذي يفرضه الاسد على اهلنا في المناطق
المحرره ومن خلال العمل بشكل ممنهج على
انهيار الاقتصاد السوري من خلال سرقه
الدولارات الموجوده في هذا البلد لصالح
اصابات النظام وانا هنا اقول ان النظام
الاسدي سيسقط اقتصاديا قبل ان يسقط عسكريا
والايام القليله القادمه ستثبت ذلك في
القريب في القريب العاجل سيصل مستوى
الدولار الواحد الى 500 ليره سوريه ولن
نستغرب على الاطلاق ان وصل فيما بعد الى
5000 ليره سوريه وهذا يعني ان راتب الموظف
السوري سيكون بين اربع الى خمس دولارات
شهريا من هنا نحن نطلب من اهلنا الا
يحتفظوا بالليره السوريه على الاطلاق لا
نريدهم ان يتحملوا تبعات اكثر مما يحتملون
هذه التبعات يجب ان يتحملها هذا النظ كل
هذا الواقع الاقتصادي الصعب الذي تشير
اليه العقيد ما ذكره سيد ذبيان وهنا اسال
سيد كمال ذبيان اذا كان اذا كانت المعارضه
شرعت في نوع من النقد الذاتي حتى اذا اخذ
هذا التعبير رغم كل المرارات والتضحيات
الا تعتقد بان النظام مقابل هذا النقد
الذاتي لم يبدي اي محاوله ولو اوليه لنوع
من من النقد الذاتي هو
ايضا بالطبع يعني
النظام النظام يتحمل مسؤوليه انا لا لست
مدافعا لا عن النظام ولا
عن الثوار انا احلل وا اقول ان ال الثوره
السوريه هي لا تحمل فكرا واضحا لا تحمل
برنامجا واضحا هي
خليط تجمع في اسطنبول في المره في المرحله
الاولى تحت عنوان المجلس الوطني
السوري الضباط ما يسمى بالجيش السوري الحر
هم ضباط انشقوا كافراد ولم ينشك ك كويه
وكتائب وك يعني ما بعرف فصائل لذلك النظام
ارتاح الان من بعد ما شعر ان هذه المعارضه
التي تواجهه هي معارضه مشتته هي معارضه
ليس لها برنامج واضح بدا الشعب السوري
يسال الى اين المصير حتى لو سقط النظام
كما يقول العقيد اقتصاديا كيف س ستقوم هذه
الثوره بمعالجه اد الوضع الاقتصادي ونحن
الان نشاهد ما يحصل في مصر هناك ثوره
مضاده او ثوره تستكمل يقوم بها شبان و
يعني ليبراليون ويساريون وديمقراطيون و
علمانيون مقابل فكر الاخوان المسلمين هم
الان اذا تخلصوا من النظام سيواجهون جبهه
النصره والقاعده وهذا ما وما حصل اليوم من
اقتتال مطلوب اوروبيا ومطلوب امريكيا كي
يسلح هذا الجيش الس الحر مقابل ان يتخلصوا
من تنظيم القاعده ومن جبهه نصرا نحن الان
ا ما يزيد ما يزيد ربما في تعميق في تعميق
هذا الموضوع هو تاخر وصول ما سمي بالسلاح
النوعي للمعارضه السوريه المسلحه بعد
الفاصل نتطرق الى انعكاسات ذلك سواء فيما
يتعلق بالتسليح الامريكي او البريطاني
وتاثير ذلك في مجريات الامور في سوريا لنا
عوده بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها تطورات المشهد
السوري اللواء فايز الدويري الان بعد كل
الحديث عن ضروره تقديم السلاح للمعارضه
السوريه المسلحه نجد نوع من التردد مازال
متواصلا امريكيا وبريطانيا ما تاثير ذلك
برايك في الواقع لابد ان يلقي بظلاله على
الثوره السوريه خاصه بعد مؤتمر الدوحه كان
هناك قرار جاء مؤتمر الدوحه بعد تصريح
الرئيس اوباما ب النيه بتسليح الجيش
السوري الحر او المعتدلين من الجيش الحر
وثم جاء مؤتمر الدوحه وكان له مقرراته
ولكن دعنا نراجع الموقف الامريكي والموقف
الفرنسي والموقف البريطاني خلال مسيره
الثوره السوريه الموقف تتسم هذه المواقف
بالتردد وبصوره مستمره تتقدم خطوتين
للامام وتعود خطوه للخلف الان احال الامر
الى اييه الى اللجان الامنيه في الكونجرس
والتي اوصت بما اوصت به كذلك المجلس
العمومي البريطاني رغم ان الصلاحيات
القانونيه للرئيس اوباما يستطيع ان يتجاوز
هذه التوصيات ولكن هو نوع من التردد يبدو
انه من اجل التقارب مع الموقف الروسي ونعم
يؤثر على مسيره الثوره ولكن هناك دول كانت
مشاركه وفاعله وكان هناك خمسه دول اقرت
بتزويد السلاح اهم هذه الدول المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وقطر وبامكانه ان يقدم
خاصه المملكه العربيه السعوديه بامكانها
ان تعوض النقص المطلوب من هذه الاسلحه
ويوجد لديها كم هائل ويوجد ولكن المشكله
انه دول مثل السعوديه او قطر او تركيا لا
تستطيع ان تقدم سلاح نوعي يفوق السقف
الامريكي المسموح به وهذا اشكال ايضا سيدي
الموقف الامريكي الان هو يتعلق بتزويد
السلاح الامريكي من الحكومه الامريكيه ولا
يت يتعلق الموقف الامريكي بفرض تحديدات
الضوء الاخضر اعطي من الاداره الامريكيه
لكافه الدول المشاركه بالدوحه ان ان ترسل
الاسلحه كل حسب طريقتها وحسب امكاناتها
اذا لا يوجد هناك سقوف على الدول المشاركه
في الدوحه ولكن هذا السقف وضع على الاداره
الامريكيه ذاتها وعلى التسليح من قبل
الاداره الامريكيه ا في موضوع السلاح وصل
اسلحه وكان هناك اعترافات سواء من اللواء
سليم ادريس او من لؤي مقداد وهناك حديث عن
كثير من انواع الاسلحه رغم انهم قالوا انه
لم تصل اسلحه مقاومه الطائرات لكن هناك
اسلحه ظهرت واستخدمت وعلى سبيل المثال ال
الاف ان 6 وهو السلاح المسؤول عن اسقاط
تقريبا 35 طائرا ميراج وسبع طائرات سخو
ومعظم الطائرات الحوامه اذا وصلت اسلحه
لكن هذه الاسلحه ليست بالحجم المطلوب
وليست بالنوعيه المطلوبه وهذا ما يؤدي الى
مراوح العمليات العسكريه في مكانها نعم
العقيد زكريه بين السلاح الذي وصل والسلاح
الذي لم يصل بعد كيف هو الوضع بالنسبه
لكم سيدي الكريم السيد رئيس هيئه الاركان
اللواء الدكتور سليم ادريس يعمل ليلا
نهارا في سبيل الحصول على التسليح وهناك
مع كل اسف حمله من النظام للتشويه صوره
الاركان ولبعث الناس على عدم الثقه
بقادتها نعم هناك تعهدات واضحه من الدول
الغربيه نتمنى ان تكون صادقه هذه المره في
ايصال السلاح وانا اوافق سياده اللواء
فائز تماما عند ما قال باننا نحن ما نريده
من الاداره الامريكيه ليس ان تسلحنا ولكن
ان ترفع اي عائق امام اي دوله تريد
التسليح هذه نقطه مهمه الامر الاخر حتى
وان لم يصلنا السلاح الامريكي ذاته فاننا
نحقق على الارض نتائج جيده وهذا ما يجب ان
يدركه الثوار تماما اي ان العزيمه
والاراده والتخطيط الجيد بما يمتلكون بين
ايديهم يحقق نتائج عاليه اعطيك مثالا نحن
خلال فتره قصيره لم تتجاوز الشهر استطاع
الجيش الحر تحرير 29 منطقه جديده بدء من
انخل جنوبا وصولا الى معسكر الاسكان في
ادلب تم تدمير 34 حاجز النظام وقطع العديد
من طرق امدادات الاهم انه استطاع تدمير 91
دبابه في مده لا تتجاوز ال يوما هذا يدلل
بانه الامكانيات رغم انها متواضعه لو تم
حسن استخدامها الصحيح فستكون نتائج جيده
من هنا انا اهيب من الجميع من جميع اخوت
من المقاتلين ان يكون التزامهم مع هيئه
الاركان التزاما حقيقيا فهيئ الاركان هي
ليست شخص هي مؤسسه عسكريه لهذا الوطن
لتدفع القتل عن اهلنا للوصول الى النصر
باقل تكلفه ممكنه ولكن ولكن ولكن التردد
التردد البريطاني التردد البريطاني
والتردد الامريكي لابد ان له دلاله معينه
سيد كمال ذبيان كيف
تراه
يعني التجربه الليبيه غير مشجعه بالنسبه
لدول
اي دول اصدقاء سوريا او اصدقاء المعارضه
السوريه يعني التجربه الليبيه دخل حلف
الناتو وسقط القذافي وقتل القذافي ما هي
الصوره اليوم في ليبيا العراق يحتل من قبل
القوات الاطلسيه والقوات الامريكيه ما هو
المشهد اليوم في العراق يتحدث العقيد عن
70% من الاراضي المحرره يعطني النموذج
الذي صنعه في هذه المناطق المحرره ماذا
حصل بالانسان السوري هل تحرر الانسان
السوري من الخوف مازال ما زالت جماعات
تكفيريه تقتل وتعدم و وتفرض الانظمه هل
هذا هو النظام السوري اوروبا لن تسلح
وفرنسا يعني توقف الرئيس الفرنسي هولاند
مؤخرا وكان اكثر المتحمسين لتسليح
المعارضه ما ما حصل في مالي ان الجماع
الجماعات المتطرفه التكفيريه التي كانت
تدعمها الدول الغربيه في في حربها ضد
القذافي وفي اسقاط القذافي انتقلت ل
لتقاتل في اماكن اخرى لذلك هنا اليوم لا
لا يستطيع لا الاوروبي ولا الامريكي ان
يقدم سلاحا للمعارضه لتعم الفوضى سوريا
وانا اسال لماذا السلاح للمعارضه ولماذا
السلاح حتى للنظام السوري اين مؤتمر جنيف
اثنين ان الحل السياسي هل لمزيد من القتل
ل للمواطنين السوريين ماذا يبشرنا العقيد
لمزيد من القتل 70% من المناطق المحرره
فليقم سلطته عليها
فل يقيم الدوله المدنيه التي يتحدث عنها
انا لا ارى ان ان كل هذه الشعارات لها
ترجمه على الارض هي شعارات ولكن ال ما سمي
بالثورات والربع العربي ما هو الا شتاء
وخريف وقد ودمار واقتتال داخلي نعم ما
تشير اليه سيد كمال ذبياني هنا اسال
العقيد زكريا الا تعتقد بان فعلا ما يشير
اليه سيد ذبيان من ان بعض الجماعات تقدم
نموذج مخيف لمستقبل سوريا هذا يجعل دول
مثل امريكا ومثل بريطانيا تتردد وهذا من
حقها كيف تعالجون هذا
الاشكال سيدي الكريم اولا للوصول الى
الربيع لابد من المرور بالشتاء وكلما كان
الشتاء قاسيا كلما كان الربيع اكثر
اخضرارا
وازدهارا اما بشان حجج الواهيه للدول
الغربيه بان هناك مجموعات متطرفه فنحن
نسال السؤال التالي لماذا لم تقم هذه
الدول بالتسليح حتى قبل الاعلان عن اي
تنظيم خارج نطاق الجيش الحر الامر الاخر
لماذا تقوم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بالقول باننا سنعمل على دراسه التسليح
للمعارضه السوريه ثم تتحجج بان جبهه
النصره موجوده هناك هي كانت تع بوجودها
قبل البدء بقرار التسليح او بعده نحن نقول
في النهايه امر واحد سواء سلحنا هذا
العالم ام لم يسلح هنا فان سلاحنا الحقيقي
هو الايمان بالله والنصر ورفع الظلم عن
اهلنا وسنستمر وسنحقق النصر في القريب
العاجل ان شاء الله من خلال الدعوه التي
اطلقها السوريون على ان نعود ونتحد وان
نصلح ما بانفسنا كي نصل الى النصر المبين
ان شاء الله نعم دكتور الدويري في نهايه
البرنامج باختصار شديد تعتقد بان الموقف
المريكي والبريطاني قد يتغير في القريب في
الواقع لم يتسم بالثبات طيله المسيره
الثوره السوريه واتوقع ان هذا الموقف
سيتغير علما بان كما تحدث العقيد بان جبهه
النصره
وا وقاعده العراق والشام هي اصبحت شماعه
اكثر منها حقيقه اذا تحدثنا عن الارهاب
وعن تدخل هذه هذه لماذا لا لماذا الغرب لا
يتحدث عن تدخل حزب الله لماذا لا يتدخل عن
يتحدث عن تدخل عصاء بالحق لماذا لا يتحدث
عن جيش المهدي لماذا لا يتحدث عن الباسيج
الايراني العالم يكيل حتى في هذه النقطه
بمكيالين عليه ان يدين التدخل الخارجي
بكافه اشكال شكرا لك اللواء الدكتور فائز
الدويري الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه شكرا لضيفنا من انطاكيا
العقيد عبد الحميد زكريا المتحدث باسم
رئاسه اركان القياده المشتركه للجيش
السوري الحر وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من بيروت
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كمال دبيان بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله وفي امان
الله
[موسيقى]